this morning everything was going great  woke up on top of it all honestly I  didn't see that I would fall  flash-forward and I really cannot  overstate I totally my ship went down  now my son might run me out of town I'd  love to change what I have done but I  don't have that kind of  here I come where I lead only send it  genius  but it turns out I was just a dumb dad  on a scale of one to ten  why did not foresee  [Music]  this dad please can do today  hello today is going great  honestly I never expected this windfall  at home my heart began to palpitate  wasn't sure how this would go down I  fully thought my ship would run aground  my daughter's a badass chess machine  I'm as giddy as  genius  my mama puts on a monster shame  one to ten  about  [Music]  in every game  can we do today I wanna see so much  [Music]  genius  on top of the game  [Music]  you